mesdames et messieurs bonjour l'homme
que nous rencontrons aujourd'hui a vécu
presque l'entièreté du dernier siècle au
rythme de l'évolution des
télécommunications au canada genre de
grand prix à transformer bell canada en
un géant des télécommunications
né à montréal en 1921 genre de grand
prix a étudié le droit à l'université
mcgill a été avocat dans le secteur
privé avant de se joindre à bell en 1966
il a occupé plusieurs postes avant de
devenir pdg en 1976 il a fondé le
conglomérat bce en 1983 alors que la
compagnie de téléphone s'impose
dorénavant dans les équipements de
télécommunications avec nortel networks
notamment et sur la scène internationale
également avec bci bell canada
international jean de grandpré a été
chancelier également de l'université
mcgill et administrateur de sociétés
nous avons rencontré jean de grandpré
il y a quelques semaines monsieur de
grandpré bonsoir ou froid merci d'être
avec nous commente allez-vous très bien
très bien la santé est excellente d'une
juge mobile délicieusement bien mais
vous avez 98 et vous avez été le grand
patron de bell canada dans le passé et
administrateur de sociétés très engagé
aussi dans la société vous avez été
chancelier de l'université mcgill
est ce que vous êtes encore engager
encore actifs aujourd'hui fut un
correctif mais pas dans les affaires
je suis encore actifs dans mes affaires
personnelles ce qui est bien différent
ouais et chez actif également dans les
affaires qualitative puisque je m'occupe
assez substantiellement dans toutes les
activités de la fondation papillon
s'occupe des enfants handicapés et
particulièrement des enfants autistes
dont je m'occupe donc vous faites ça
vous êtes actif et vous êtes en bonne
santé c'est quoi la recette est pour
être en bonne santé comme vous l'êtes à
l'âge que vous avez
des gènes de mamette recommencer oui les
jeunes de mon père parce que mon père
est mort à 65 ans et pas recommandable
n'arrive longtemps mais il est un peu
responsable parce qu'ils mangent
beaucoup de chocolat
il était frappée avec un cancer
alors là pas été très long mais depuis
moi j'ai vécu une façon active très
active mais je peux le soin de ma santé
je prenais soin de ma diète le prenez
soin de mes activités de façon à avoir
une vie personnelle balancer alors que
ma vie familiale n'était pas balancer
c'est vrai je n'étais jamais à la maison
mais c'est pour les équilibres ça c'est
paris qui veulent envoyer dans tout ça
pas du tout pas du tout heureusement que
j'avais une femme qui a pris la relève
pour et est donc vous êtes aujourd'hui
là devant nous à 98 vous avez participé
à la rédaction de ce livre écrit par
daniel stanton et hervé antil l'héritage
d'un géant on parle de gens de grand
prix grand visionnaire de bell téléphone
à bce
quand on parle de bell telephone bce je
trouve que ça illustre très bien votre
carrière chez bell parce que vous avez
fait passer cette entreprise là d'une
compagnie de téléphone à un géant
finalement des télécommunications lebel
qu'on connaît le bce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est vous qu'il l'avait
développé en quelque sorte dans les
années 70 et 80 il avait raison quand je
suis arrivé c'était uniquement une
compagnie de téléphone quand je suis
parti c'était une compagnie de
télécommunications et qui avait une
réputation internationale
nous avons eu alité
du contrat en arabie saoudite qui fut un
succès ouais nous avions des compagnies
d'impression fut également international
et nous avions plusieurs opérations qui
était international ouais
ce qui est impressionnant c'est que vous
dites puis là je veux citer un extrait
de votre livre vous dites dans le livre
notre but c'était de faire de belles une
compagnie de télécommunications et non
plus seulement une entreprise de
téléphone nous n'avions aucunement
l'intention de devenir un diffuseur de
radio de télévision un opérateur de
télévision par câble ou un éditeur qui
façonneraient la pensée du pays
nous voulions seulement avoir la
possibilité de relayer les signaux émis
par les radiodiffuseurs et les
télédiffuseurs cette cause cette
entreprise-là a quand même pris une
expansion elie devenu quelque chose de
très grand n'est ce pas évidemment mais
ce n'était pas quand je parle de ça
c'était au moment où le conseil
d'administration de la compagnie alors
que j'étais chef du contentieux avait
donné instruction de changer la loi
constitutive de bell canada se dit qu'il
se plaît à ce moment là la compagnie de
téléphone bell canada
le téléphone company of canada et s'est
habillé loup il fallait faire un nom
plus plus moderne
c'est ça et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire avec certaines difficultés
et puis il s'agissait également ce
moment alors de rendre légal le contrôle
de bell canada deux latéraux pays de
téléphone bell canada de nowruz northern
electric à ce moment là qui est devenue
une norme networks est venu nortel
networks beaucoup plus tard et qu'il ya
eu une fin triste oui effectivement
et donc en fait ce que vous vouliez
faire et vous étiez avec d'autres
personnes à ce moment là mais vous
vouliez libéré en quelque sorte belle
parce que bell était dans un carcan
vous vouliez lui donner
coût plus de possibilité de grandir de
se développer ah là là vous parlez de la
création de bcr ici oui il était après
nous étouffer littéralement parce que
tout ce que nous faisions à l'extérieur
de la téléphonie proprement dit devait
être au bénéfice des abonnés est rien du
tout pour le bénéfice des actionnaires
qui en fait prenez le risque de toutes
les entreprises que nous avions à
travers le monde évidemment le contrat
en arabie saoudite ce fut un succès on a
fait la compagnie quand je dis on a fait
la compagnie a fait du profit
extraordinaire avec le contrat ouais en
arabie saoudite nous avons obtenu de la
réputation internationale d'être la plus
la meilleure compagnie de téléphone
parce que beaucoup de pays voulait la
voir le contrat j'ai vu ça vous dit le
président des états unis est d'avoir le
droit président la france va loin dans
les terres à la voir le roi et puis
monsieur trudeau n'a pas levé le petit
doigt
pierre trudeau n'a pas levé le petit
et donc c'est vous qui êtes à les
convaincre l'arabie saoudite
évidemment c'est moi qui ai eu des
contacts avec l'arabie saoudite mais
j'ai eu également des contacts avec ceux
qui ont été nos partenaires dans ce
contrôle à ça remonte à un certain temps
c'est des entreprises qu'on prend pour
acquis aujourd'hui mais ça remonte quand
même vraiment à 76 quand même et là à ce
moment à la dallas 76 et 1968 et non
vous l'avez compris car à ce moment là
le poste que vous occupez comme grand
patron de bell canada qui va devenir bce
ce poste-là est considéré comme le poste
le plus important secteur privé au
canada comme aux jo c'est ce qu'on dit
et c'est encore l'un des plus importants
d'ailleurs dans le monde privé au canada
est ce que c'est votre meilleur coût
celui de l'arabie saoudite le val moré
york ou non mon meilleur coup c'est la
création de baisser karima ça c'est en
1983 exactement parce que
c'est quelque chose de plus difficile ça
la vitesse avait-il demandé est tentée
auparavant et ça n'aurait pas réussi et
c'est pour ça que quand j'ai lancé
l'idée de créer une compagnie qui serait
le holding ou la compagnie mère de bell
canada
c'était un lieu assez loin c'est allé
assez loin donc j'avais ce holding qui a
été créé bell canada d'autres
entreprises également vous vous êtes
parti en 1989 exactement à ce moment là
ja bell canada qui qui qui va
relativement bien
il ya nordine qui deviendra nortel
networks qui va carrément s'effondrer 12
à 15 ans plus tard est ce qu'à ce moment
quand vous partez là on voit pas ça
venir chez nortel l'effondrement
reconnaître pas encore c'est arriver
graduellement tout un effondrement comme
celui là ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
se produit du jour au lendemain
nous avions engagé avec beaucoup de
recommandations
un monsieur sttl polster qui se prenait
pour un autre avant qui devait sauver
tout le monde devait l'appeler d'apple
stoll d'abord avant on faisait pour
beaucoup dans l'entreprise et il nous a
lancé l'idée au conseil d'administration
que nous dépassions à peu près un
milliard par année à rechercher en
développement chez nortel à ce moment là
qu'ils étaient le caire dans le fond de
l'activité les certains de fruits et
puis il nous a dit que vous aviez vous
fait de très bonnes recherches
vous avez de très bons résultats mais
ces résultats vous coûte trop cher quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui vous est
recommandé par nombre incroyable de
chefs d'entreprises à travers les états
unis
vous commencez à des peut-être que on
dépense beaucoup
puis on a des bons résultats mais on
pourrait peut-être savoir les mêmes
résultats à moindre coût peut-être
raison peut-être qu'il a raison mais ça
prend quelques temps avant que vous
voyez les résultats
face de son approche lorsque tout à coup
on a réalisé que ce qui l'intéressait
beaucoup plus c'était d'augmenter la
valeur des options dont il était le
détenteur parce que les bénéfices
augmenter quand vous enlevez 1 millions
dans la recherche c'est un million qui
vont pas dans les dépenses alors le
titre montait les valeurs de ces options
augmenté et ont tout à coup au cesi
c'est fini et on l'a mis à la dore au
conseil d'administration
il a dit si vous acceptez pas que je
vous présente je démissionne au lieu
demandé de sortir du conseil
d'administration est sorti quand il est
rentré il était sorti de la compagnie
s'est fait aussi vite que ça sauf que
nortel s'est quand même effondré oui
mais l'a fait fondre et un peu à cause
de ça au début parce que nous ne
trouvions pas rencontré les les scop
seul ce que promettait à nos acheteurs
on ne pourrait pas le le livret où on ne
pouvait pas le livrer à temps sont très
mauvais alors c'est pour ça que le gadjo
helmand la valeur de la compagnie abc et
en plus nous avions un ami à ce moment
alors que la compagnie tap eu lieu à ce
moment là le conseil d'administration a
nommé un homme et john ross genre en
europe
j'en étais vraiment le patron très
identifiée à nortel à la fasm hamas à ce
moment là pour été il a été un très très
beau rechercheurs et président du centre
de recherche bien arbel northern trust
et mais quand il était là comme
administrateur il n'avait pas la même
capacité
et il a acheté à des prix faramineux des
entreprises qui n'en valait pas la peine
avec le résultat qu'on connaît et un
hôtel s'est effondré
toutes ces histoires que vous racontez
là
exif à votre esprit encore au mal
logement pourquoi malheureusement mais
parce que parce qu'il ya des mamans
parce que des noix j'étais président du
conseil de nortel et moment donné alors
que c'était la compagnie de
télécommunications cherche et
d'équipements en télécommunications qui
avait vent dans les voiles
ouais et une fois que je suis parti
la compagnie effet faudrait alors
évidemment boudebouz est triste à ce
moment là on dit de vous que vous êtes
un homme pragmatique
têtu simplificateur charismatique un
homme du monde avec de l'entregent de
l'intelligence un bon jugement et une
immense expérience j'ai recensé
plusieurs des qualificatifs qui se
retrouve dans ce livre je trouvais ça
intéressant de vous dire d'un coup c'est
comme ça c'est une route votre précédent
livre et vous dites dans l'évier deux
choses que je veux citer pour les gens
qui écoutent vous dites par exemple
prenez la décision et ayez l'humilité de
reconnaître vos erreurs
vous avez appliqué sa wii durant toute
votre vie oui vous pouvez pas réussir si
vous ne venez tôt ce mois ci
premièrement il faut donner crédit à
tout ce qui vous entoure vous ne pouvez
pas faire ça celle où j'avais besoin
d'acolytes j'avais besoin de gens qui
sont beaucoup plus verser dans les
domaines divers où vous devez opéré
alors vous leur faites confiance
six journées vos résultats merci
beaucoup
si ça va pas on peut les changer mais il
faut absolument avoir le respect du
succès de vos acolytes
d'ailleurs vous dites qu'il est une
deuxième station que je faire de vous
mes employés ne travaillez pas pour moi
il travaillait avec moi toujours et
toujours de ce vous êtes allez
rencontrer vos employés à plusieurs
reprises est allé partout rencontrer vos
employés c'est important dans des
circonstances difficiles parfois
le dans vos livres si vous vouliez qu'on
en parle je suis allé rencontrer à une
heure du matin des téléphonistes parce
qu'on m'avait appris que si on fermait
le je perçois comme le petit restaurant
si vous voulez vous ou le lac entre un
endroit où on pouvait cuir une omelette
ah oui d'accord sauf une soupe avoir de
ce café frais en tout cas petites choses
comme ça qu'elles étaient les falaises
de nuit apprécié beaucoup parce qu' elle
ne pouvait pas aller au restaurant ou
ailleurs à ce moment là et c'est les
téléphonistes de nuit avait
habituellement une vie intime difficile
elle était obligée de travailler la nuit
parce que elle avait une mère loue des
enfants malades dont l époux malade
alors il fallait en prendre soin et
j'avais appris que le directeur de ce
département la voulait fermer ce que
j'appelle la petite cuisine est puis la
cuisine est la crise et n'ont pas besoin
d'être pour sauver 50 75 mille pièces
par année
ça n'avait aucun sens c'est pour ça que
je suis dit rencontrer je suis allé les
rencontrer
à une heure du matin pour le dire mais
vous avez votre cuisine est et un autre
endroit à une autre occasion il a fallu
que faire en tout cas la différence
entre le bien être des employés et les
résultats financiers on m'avait dit si
on sauve 75 cents mille deux cent mille
dollars
si on change la façon d'opérer dans nos
centres de travail surtout à l'étranger
on peut sauver beaucoup d'argent si on
fait travailler les gens pendant dix
heures par jour quatre jours par semaine
au lieu de 8 heures par jour cinq jours
par semaine vous avez 40 heures oui mais
vous ne passez pauvre stable
à faire je travaille qui n'est pas
payant en conduisant les camions sur les
routes
avant d'arriver à l'endroit où il faut
planter le protocole avec les résultats
que j'avais géré toutes sortes
recommandations j'ai décidé d'aller sur
place
il ne suis pas certain et à cette heure
je te rendrai à black lake près
d'asbestos pour rencontrer les ouvriers
et leur demande qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
là vous aviez trois groupes les
célibataires
il aimait beaucoup l'idée d'avoir trois
jours de d'accord j'ai faut célébrer oui
l'autre qui était marié il a joué par
jour mais je prenais moyer parce que ma
femme et moi on va dépasser pendant
trois jours ça va me coûter cher j'aime
mieux pas voir ça et finalement un
troisième groupe kimasi ne fait jamais
ça vous allez mettre mon mariage à nous
parce que je vais arriver trop tard
je ne verrai pas des enfants ma femme a
regardé le souper pendant deux heures
pour les enfants l'après 7 garder chaud
pour moi c'est fatal où est mon ménage
alors j'ai décidé qu'on était pour
rester cinq ans ces cinq jours alors
tout le monde parce que vous avez écouté
vos employés c'est parce que je suis un
con ce respect pour les employés oui ces
produits c'est important cette saison ce
sont les humains qu'il faut
l'accompagner ce point de parent pauvre
s il peut donner des orientations et se
donner début mai
pour l'heure le quotidien dans
l'entreprise ce sont les employés sont
leurs qui vont faire le travail
les téléphonistes vont répondre au
téléphone les planteurs de beaux tous
ceux qui auraient profité les femmes
souhaitent il faut mettre les câbles
suspense les indiens ce même chose et
c'est quoi vos projets aujourd'hui à 98
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
faites pas ce que je fais si je m'occupe
beaucoup de la fondation papillon oui la
fondation papillon à cette fondation
qui me tient à coeur parce que là une
histoire dans la famille parce que
aujourd'hui ce sont des enfants autistes
dont je m'occupe à entre benoît qui
s'appelle le cas de grand prix où j'ai
permis à la fondation de de bâtir sa
droit résidence pour des enfants eu un
gymnase pour les mauvais jours
oui est évidemment un bistrot pour
nourrir tous ces enfants là parce qu'à
certains moments il peut y avoir jusqu'à
sa soixante et ça m'occupe beaucoup
vous avez souvent le qu elle est souvent
et aucun jeu aucun je rencontre j'ai
rencontré puis je rencontre encore des
ingénieurs d'architectes l'entrepreneur
ouais je rencontre évidemment le
directeur monsieur duchesneau sur une
base hebdomadaire
on a toujours quelques problèmes à
régler quand ils m'appellent je tue
besoin d'argent
et puis je m'occupe beaucoup de ça et
puis je m'occupe est également de mise
affaire personnelle parce que quand vous
êtes aussi occupé vous ne vous occupez
pas de vos affaires personnelles ce sont
les affaires de la personne de la
compagnie s'y promener dessus c'est ça
c'est ce que je fais maintenant vous
faites encore du vélo stationnaire
oh oui j'suis exercice je lis énormément
je dis peut-être un livre par semaine
serey die biographie de l'histoire
quelques romans une fois de temps à
autre à ce moment si je suis à lire les
biographies d'alain bouchard
oui de costard de couche tard j'ai
également en réserve
le biographie de frigo en quoi et j'ai
lu à peu près et biographies de
président d
j'ai lu les biographies d'à peu près
tous les premiers ministres du canada
sans exception donc vous restez éveillés
intellectuellement et physiquement aussi
avec avec ce vélo là alors je vais vous
souhaiter longue vie
monsieur de grand prix vous êtes en
excellente forme c'est un vrai plaisir
merci beaucoup pour l'inspiration jours
merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité